had made this possible and this is the
first time in the history of this state
that a white police officer has been
convicted
less known convicted of a murder
this is the first time in a long ray of
fights
that we've seen three counts
guilty at all three we don't
find pleasure in this we don't celebrate
a man going to jail we would have rather
george be alive amen but we celebrate
that we because young people
white and black some castigated many
that are here tonight
marched and kept marching and kept
many of them down on but they kept much
and wouldn't let this die and this
is an assurance to them that if we don't
give up
that we can win some rounds but the war
and the fight is not over just two days
from now
we're going to have to deal with the
funeral
of dante wright in this same
county the same area we still have
cases to fight but this gives us the
energy to fight on
and we are determined that we're going
to fight until we make federal law
yes the george floyd justice
and policing act yes must be lawful
we want to thank all that
especially the attorney general and the
governor
and others we want to thank president
back
who the first time he came out of his
house
during the campaign he flew to houston
and met with the family and attorney
crump and i
and he sat there and i will never forget
he's he said to
george's daughter that i heard you say
your father
is gonna change the world well we can
now tell george's daughter she was right
her father has began the changing of the
world
for real but before we do anything
we first want to pray and thank god
because somehow god made a way he had
mercy
we believe in a god that can even get
through the cracks in the jury room
and bring conscience and bring truth
and that jury we want to thank them for
letting god
give them the strength wherever they are
tonight
we want them to know we broke down in
tears
when we heard the verdict we had to hold
each other and hug in tears
because too many nights we've cried many
of us for decades
spent nights in jail but today we can
wipe our tears away
and fight off for another day there's
sunlight
we're going to keep going until we bring
it for the eric garners and the brianna
taylor whose boyfriend is here tonight
kenny walker sean bell
so many that did not get this night this
night is for them let us pray
let's lock arms and pray like we can
folks
where come on friend where's for long
brother chris get the next attorney
general there let's pray
dear god we thank you for giving us the
strength to stand together
sometimes we would question each other
sometimes we say this is just going to
be a waste of time
but somehow you touch us in the midnight
hours
and teach us to hold on and that if we
would be
faithful over a few things you'd give us
the victory over many
we thank you because we know it was not
any doing of ours
but your loving kindness and your tender
mercy
it made tonight possible bless those
that worked
that made this prosecution something
they couldn't deny
bless those policemen that got on the
stand
and testified against another policeman
bless the jury that listened to the
evidence
and didn't listen to those that may
criticize them for doing this bless
the prosecutor keith ellison and his
staff
yes that did their job even though they
didn't know what the outcome would be
bless ben crump in a special way
that worked tirelessly that jumped on
planes and left his family
to make sure that justice would rain
down
thank you for all of the civil and human
rights leaders that stood up
and we thank you for the nameless
grandmas and grandpas
that will get on their knees and ask you
to give us a victory this time
and lord as we give you the thanks
and give you the praise let george know
that his name
is going down in history they may have
put the knee on his neck
but he will now be a figure that we will
take the knees off
our necks now and we give you the praise
thank you and god we give you the glory
these blessings we ask in your name amen
amen amen
let me say that i want to bring on now
a man who has symbolized the fight
for justice he didn't seek the role
but he rose to the occasion america
for many years didn't have someone to
stand for us
the last four years we didn't have an
attorney general's office that would
even hear outcry
but we had been raised to believe that
god always has a ram in the bush
and god has a way of taking the most
humble of people
and raising numbers up we had an
attorney general in black america
that has represented these cases with
the acumen and skill
of one that was raised in the south but
came to claim
this nation in a new direction i bring
you the attorney general
for black america ben crom
[Applause]
thank you reverend al sharpton not only
for
your mentorship not only for being a
great civil rights leader but for being
a moral authority
especially making sure no matter what
happened
that we always maintained the moral high
ground
knowing that we were on the right side
of history as we fought for justice
for george perry floyd jr
say his name
i am uh but a member of a great team
of very talented attorneys and i'm going
to acknowledge there
yeah we got the omegas and the captains
reverend jackson
in the opposition that's right uh
i want to acknowledge these great group
of lawyers and then the family members
uh two or three of the lawyers will
address you
and then that time we will hear from
the family members before we take any of
your questions
uh i want to acknowledge
uh a great lawyer from chicago illinois
uh one of the best i've ever had a
chance to work with
attorney tony ramon nucci
i wanna recognize my partner on the
front line
in this case one of the best lawyers
at being on them uh he hails from
atlanta georgia attorney chris stewart
yeah his law partner attorney justin
miller
attorney madeline simmons
uh a great minnesota lawyers
attorney jeff storms raise your hand
yeah
attorney michelle goodell
and who else we got here anybody else
all right we have attorney scott
masterson who's not
present uh attorney pavani
i i said michelle we got michelle all
right
uh it's just a great group of lawyers
and i want to let you know who we have
present here with the family
here in minneapolis for this historic
day
we have george floyd's brothers
we have philonous floyd
we have rodney floyd we have uh
brandon williams who's george floyd's
nephew
but was more like a son to him they call
him woo back in the third ward
we have keita floyd filonis's wife
we have oh what time is that
new york way yeah
[Music]
we got terence floyd um his sisters who
are not with us but
we should absolutely acknowledge uh
bridget floyd who hails from north
carolina
his sisters latonya and zsa who hail
from houston texas
we have his cousins uh sharita mcgee
tedra mcgee and tara brown
and we have uh the mother of his
daughter gianni floyd we have roxy
washington
and we have gianna
[Applause]
and so i'll i'll i'll make some brief
remarks and then we're going to have
attorney stuart
[Music]
i know it's a big fruit
a.d ain't dave
the man he came from minneapolis with
anna darrell so i'll make some brief
remarks and then we're going to
have attorney student attorney ramon
nucci make some brief remarks
and then we're going to hear from this
family
and we're going to try to
leave here today knowing that america is
a better country
america less
pause for a moment
to proclaim this historical moment
not just for the legacy of george floyd
but for the legacy of america
the legacy of trying to
make america for all americans
so that george floyd's victory
and america's quest
for equal justice under the law would be
intertwined
america let's frame this moment
as a moment where we finally
are getting close to living up to our
declaration of independence
that we hold these truths to be
self-evident
that all men are created equally that
they're endowed by their creator
with certain inalienable rights that
amongst them are life
and liberty in the pursuit of happiness
where america that means all of us
that means black people that means
hispanic people
that means native people that means
asian people
that means all of us america we frame
this moment
for all of us not just for george floyd
this is a victory
for those who champion humanity over
inhumanity
those who champion justice over
injustice
those who champion morals over
immorality america
let's lean into this moment
and let's make sure river now that this
moment
will be documented
for our children yet unborn
as they continue on the journey to
justice
knowing that the blood of george floyd
will give them a trail to find a way to
a better america a more just america
a more just america where briana taylor
gets an opportunity to
sleep in peace at night without the
police resting in her front door
a more just america where mod aubry gets
to run
free and not be lynched for jogging
while black
a more just america where jacob blake
and anthony mclean and walter scott
and laquan mcdonald and all these other
black men
terence crutcher who was shot in the
back
while running away like dante wright was
just a week ago because for some reason
black men running away from the police
is more dangerous
than young white men who commit mass
murders
and walk towards the police with an
assault
weapon reverend like cal
written house in kenosha wisconsin wow
america let this be the precedent yes
let this be the precedent where we
live up to the high ideals and the
promises when we say
liberty and justice for all
those sunkist children
are included in all
those children who overcame slavery
the middle passage the dred scott
decision
classified ferguson jim crow
and his much smarter wildest son jim
crow jr
esquire let this be the precedence
where we overcome systematic racism and
oppression
and that we are a better people
and we will leave our children
a better world a better world for us
all at this time
we will hear from a great lawyer
because nobody does this alone it's
always a team effort
and we have the lawyers the preachers
the civil rights leaders the education
leaders the activists let's give a big
round of applause
for the activists that's right the
people who stayed in the streets
the people who came nationally
but more importantly the people who were
here locally
who were standing up for georgetown on
38th and chicago
avenue day in and day out
silky the people who win coho wins stay
quiet
reverend jasmine people follow your own
example
donald williams will be here
[Applause]
so we love you donna without further ado
my brother attorney chris stewart
first
the first thing that happened when
we heard the verdict is that we all
teared up
and embraced so don't confuse
these tears thinking that they are
sorrow
because those were the tears that
happened to african americans when
they're pulled over constantly on the
side of the road
and no they can't get help those are the
tears of the victims that we've seen
time and time again be shot in the back
choked over loose cigarettes or killed
for no reason
and justice never comes those are the
tears that
someone will weep tomorrow when they are
taken advantage of
in an interaction with law enforcement
but today the tears are pure joy yes
pure joy and pure shock because days
like this don't
happen the whole world should not have
to rally to get justice
for one man but that's what happened
this wasn't a city case this wasn't one
family's case this was the entire
world's case
and justice finally came but it
shouldn't have to be so hard to attain
this level of justice
in cases like this when we can see with
our own eyes the only difference is the
color of the skin
and that's the change that we all want
that's what i've changed that's
outrageous
yes law enforcement have a dangerous job
they have to carry a spear
and a sword and a shield but all too
often african-americans only get the
spear
or the sword we need more of the shield
because this is not a case against every
officer my life was saved by two law
enforcement officers years ago so i will
never throw every cop under the bus
but we will put more cops in jail when
you kill someone for no reason just
because they're black
and we can find a unifying purpose
between law enforcement
and the african-american community
by changes starting with the george
floyd justice and policing act
a beautifully written bill that will
help protect the community
and solve policies and the main question
is will we let politics divide us
because that's what happens
republican or democrat you're going to
stick to your side unify as ben has been
saying
as rev has been saying and get this bill
passed
and save people so that you don't have
to board up your own cities
for situations like this
and if not we'll see you next time when
it's time to vote
you've seen what's happened across this
country
and we shouldn't have to be so happy
when we finally get one but we are in
celebration
for gianna for roxy who has stood strong
this entire time
for the brothers and sisters for the
activists like tamika and everybody else
for this entire group and it wouldn't
have happened without
every single one of y'all white or black
people out there praying for this family
getting love and support and we love all
of you all
let this be a changing point in america
for policing in a positive way
and less unified thank you my brother
[Applause]
attorney tony ramonucci from chicago
illinois
[Applause]
good afternoon everybody as ben said my
name is tony romanucci
i'm smiling here today not for myself
but really for the entire country and
for the world that's watching
i know that on behalf of the family and
for everyone who's here today
that we stand here before you feeling a
tremendous amount of joy
and eternal hope for me
36 years ago i was a young public
defender in cook county
reverend jackson i know you know that
place very well
and that's where i was introduced to the
marginalization
of black and brown people and for now
this is the 36th year i've seen it come
through
i really feel that this country has
turned a corner
but i'm going to tell you it was a tough
corner to turn
and it couldn't have been done i'm going
to reach out to you all the press
for spreading the message to the
strength and wisdom of ben trump
to you reverend al sharpton reverend
jackson
the attorneys chris justin madeline jeff
michelle pavani nicolette ian
all the teams in all the cities in this
country
the attorney general and the magnificent
prosecution team
they did it right they they tied up
every
loose they tied up every loose threat
for that jury
they let them follow it right through
they showed them how to prosecute
and how to convict and we are so
grateful
but make no mistake we are not done
the george floyd policing and reform act
must pass the senate yes we now know
that today
police can and will be held accountable
for needless death this death never
should have happened
george should have been alive somewhere
with his daughter gianna playing on a
playground
from now on everyone's on notice that
police will be held accountable
that we will be held accountable too
this whole country should be held
accountable
but police are special i am so thankful
to all of you
i am hopeful for a greater america
for a great great uh vote of confidence
i will tell you that that speaker pelosi
called us not once today
but twice our speaker is a great leader
she is somebody that wants to see this
through we have a great president
who wants to see this through we have
one little hiccup in between
let's get this past the senate let's get
justice in america
once and for all and forever one last
comment
i met a young lady yesterday her name
was lamaya
she said one thing to me that i promised
her that i would repeat today
lamaya is not part of the of the floyd
family
she is part of the wright family and she
said one thing
and i promised her i would say it today
we are all god's children
thank you lamaya
thank you tony
[Music]
and i know speaker pelosi called uh we
need to acknowledge
when we were at the courthouse and we
were leaving
i got one of those calls and we stopped
everything no idea
and it was uh chris and
uh philonous and uh
roxy and all of us justin as we walking
out we stopped in this sentence
because uh president joe biden called to
talk about what a moment this was for
america
and how we have to use this moment to
build on
so we want to acknowledge president
biden
acknowledging that we are all a better
america today
isn't that what he said okay
okay and we we got so many good stuff
people to thank jim mcgruff and michelle
adna
roma all these people who've been
working you know in the
uh supporting our lawyers silky
everybody
but briefly we want to have we can't be
in minneapolis and not have
a representative whether jeff and
michelle want to come up and say a word
great minnesota uh co-counselor jeff
stars
michelle
so i just briefly want to say
i love this city i love this state
and no longer can we be known
for these massively infamous
failures in civil rights wow
we owe our children and our community
more
from this moment further from this
conviction now we have to be leaders
in this country on civil rights
and everyone standing up here will work
tirelessly
until that happens and i challenge
everybody else
in minnesota to make that same effort
thank you
thank you all right can we because
they're trying to get everybody take a
step back
uh let's try to make napoleon let's try
to make the podium just everybody take a
step back we're gonna have the family
we go we're gonna have this we're gonna
have the family come up
okay okay
we're gonna have the family uh come
and try to greet you all uh
so let's see you got it back
up too so the camera is trying to the
trim
camera's trying to get the podium yeah
so uh
right now
okay right now we gonna bring up
a man who when i first met him uh
tony i remember he all he could do is
cry
because he was heartbroken
he was heartbroken because remember
and so many times we are
it's a case to us tamika is a cause
you know my son is a hashtag but to them
this was their flesh and blood
mario they slept in the bed with george
i mean there's stories that they tell
you know this was a close family
he tells those stories right now how he
used to pee on george
but yeah he has become so
dignified and articulate and expressed
and not
just the fight for justice for his
family
not just to fight for justice for black
america
but he really has become so articulate
and saying we have to fight
for all americans
mr falonis floyd
hey uh my nephew he calling me uh baby
ale jesse calling me
steve harvey but man it's
it's i feel relieved today that i
finally have the opportunity
to for hopefully getting some sleep
uh a lot of days that i i pray
and i hope and i was speaking everything
into existence
i said i have faith that he will be
convicted
it's been a long journey and it's been
less than a year
and the person that comes to my mind
is 1955 and to me he was the first
george floyd
now that was immature
wow i did uh
was on cnn with deborah watts
and she just brought him back to life
people forgot about him yeah but
he was the first george floyd
but today you have the cameras
all around the world to see and show
what happened to my
brother it was a motion picture
the world seeing his life being
extinguished
and i could do nothing but watch
especially in that courtroom
over and over and over again as my
brother was
murdered times
they're getting harder every day
10 miles away from him mr wright
dante wright yeah he should still be
here
we ought to always understand that
have to watch we will have to do this
for life we have to protest
because it seems like this is a never in
the cycle
yeah yeah ravenel always told me
we gotta keep fighting
i'ma put up a fight every day because
i'm not just fighting for george anymore
i'm fighting for everybody around this
world
i get calls i get dms people
from brazil from ghana from germany
everybody london italy they're all
saying the same thing
we won't be able to breathe until you're
able to breathe
today we are able to breathe again
[Applause]
ms gorner i told you we'll get justice
and we still we're going to fight for
you too
we're going to fight for everybody thank
you all so much for just giving us this
time
because we're here and we're not going
anywhere
and i want to thank all the protesters
all the attorneys
who stepped up all the activists who
stepped
up and many who think they're not
activists but advocates
thank you all amen because justice for
george means
freedom for all
[Music]
[Applause]
terence floyd we will have terence floyd
george's brother from new york city
oh man so many emotions right now
but i'm very thankful and grateful
grateful for the people in this world
for the support the prayers the the love
that was shown
whether you sent it so by social media
or whether you sent it
emails or however just we just
appreciate the love
i appreciate the team
the trump law team
i call him hunk i call him up he built
the bonner relationship
through this whole journey i appreciate
him
he will call me i'm all the way in new
york he'll call me and check up on me
and actually i'm all right
because i'm the only one up there
everybody else is down south
so but he he he never thought a robbery
to check up on me and i'm grateful for
that
i'm grateful for robert sharpton
he been fighting a long time long time
man reverend jesse jackson
yeah thank you it's a lot of history
here
history is here this is monumental
reverend justin jesse jackson al
sharpton they lived to see this
their fight wasn't in vain it just
didn't happen when they did it
but it happened now amen and they're
here to see it
and be proud of it
they go back to when he did that prayer
service
my family is a family that will not back
down from prayer
yes
and i believe because of prayer
we got the verdict we wanted amen
amen we got on our knees
some of us stood up but we asked the
right person we asked the right one
we said god we need justice yeah
we need it now
and he answered
i'm huh man i'm just i'm just grateful
i'm grateful that my grandmother my
mother my aunts they just got to see
this history made
i'm even great i'm i'm grateful my
brother's not here i'm grateful and i'm
proud of him
i would salute him at every every day of
my life i would salute him
because he showed me how to be strong he
showed me how to be respectful
he showed me how to speak my mind
i'm gonna miss him but now i know he's
in history
what a day to be a floyd man
thank you thank you
terence now we will hear from
george's baby brother rodney floyd
you know what i'm gonna say this first i
would like to thank all the
advocates the activists i'd like to
thank the people
thankful for everybody that stayed out
there making a statement with us
encouraging us on our dark days
dark nights we had them and you know we
got so many messages flooding in from
social media sites came free tomorrow
it's so many and but you know what
thank everyone each and everyone so many
people at grocery stores we walk in we
hear from the elders you know i believe
in respecting the others giving you guys
all the respect men and women and i hear
them walk up in the grocery store
stop me they i'm a masked up face and a
hat and a mask and they think hey i'm
looking at the side of your face
let me talk to you i know who you are we
have a whole they'll stop and hold a
great conversation telling me
what they experienced as a child what
they saw and what they need for change
and they say we are here for you and
this is everywhere i go my brother go we
all go
and thank you people for the love in the
streets i'm thanking everyone because we
couldn't have did this and this is the
victory for
all of us there's no color boundary on
this this is
everyone who's been held down pinned
down yeah
and you know what people are we standing
together in unity and this right here
like thank our team
this attorney being trump yeah
the witnesses donald williams i would
like to thank the jury
i mean everybody thank god that's all
thank god almighty thank you
and you know what people we not done yet
and
my brother joy he's smiling his
beautiful daughter's here
gianna baby you're so beautiful you're
so smart
roxy you have my heart baby
thank you for holding gianna keeping us
strong i know
how hard it is i know how hard it is
we'd like to thank everyone who helped
out the taste love to thank this jury
from
having our hearts and mind says that we
all
they know what the jury had to say
mindset we all had guilty as charged
i'd love to thank them i'd like to thank
again everybody depress it all
but for george this fight is not over
we're going to stand here together we're
going to try to get the jaws floor there
pass yes the act has to be past people
it has to be we're going to keep
pressure
on the senate everybody thank y'all all
for coming
george i know that he love all y'all
thank y'all
all right
and next we gonna have a man who
will him in him and george used to text
each other all the time
uh congresswoman sheila jackson lee i
always talk about
cuny homes houston texas
back there rocks i think y'all call them
woo
we're going to hear from brandon
williams was like a son to george
it's very emotional day for me and i
don't really have words
i'm overwhelmed with joy but i do want
to start by saying thank you
first off thank you to all you guys um
advocating protesting in the middle of a
pandemic putting your lives and safety
on the line we appreciate that
um especially to our legal team ben tony
justin um chris justin back here
um definitely definitely thank you to
keith edison and his
[Applause]
i think they did an team job from start
to finish
um all of the evidence
all the witnesses everything proved
exactly what we saw in that video
but yet we still questioning the
decision of the jury
and i wonder why often times this system
fails us as black men and women in
america
with all evidence there everything
pointing
to a guilty verdict we somehow still
don't get the guilty verdict
or in some cases i got my good friend
kenny walker back here
we don't even get charges
so today is a pivotal moment
um for america
it's something this country's needed for
a long time now
yes and hopefully today is the start of
that when i set up people at a moment
we need change in this broken system it
was built to oppress us
it was built against us
often times
we see people who are supposed to
supposed to protect and serve
supposed to protect the serve
they do the total opposite on the first
day of trial
real short and we had a press conference
and we kneeled for eight minutes and 46
seconds
and when i got up and it was my turn to
speak
i said that every time i come out here
it's hard
because it's the exact place where they
took somebody from me that i love
and i absolutely dislike coming here
but i also said this time it was easy
we came for one thing and one thing only
that was justice for george floyd
and today that's what we got
[Applause]
so this time it wasn't hard at all
it wasn't hard at all i'm big on faith
in prayer
i had a lot of faith but i was also
optimistic
we need police reform bad yeah
these guys are able to wear badge and go
out in the field
which means that they're qualified and
trained to do their job
at a high level but when you shoot and
kill a man that's running away from you
that doesn't pose a threat
either you're not qualified under
trained
or it's a choice and you want to kill
black men and women
it's either one or the other and i think
today
keith ellison and his team prove that
just because you are the law you're not
above the law
yeah we need
each and every officer to be held
accountable
and until then
it's still scary to be a black man i
want an american county police
yeah so when i say today is a pivotal
moment
it's a chance for america to
take a turn in the right direction and
write a lot of wrongs so that we don't
keep adding to these names
so that little girls and boys like
gianna are not growing up fatherless
so their families don't feel the pain we
feel it's a lot of sleepless nights
no family should go through there and
hopefully our country take
a turn in the right direction today
and this this day in history proves that
it was a turning point thank you
we're gonna hear from just a few more
family members and then we'll try to get
to your questions
but i'll be remiss cause brandon i gotta
acknowledge his man cliff who worked for
us
and and he talked about kenny walker
chris as we talk about all the brothers
we can never forget
that they're killing black women as well
and so
we got to remember brianna taylor we got
to remember ariana jefferson
we got to remember sandra bland and we
know
tamika mallory now may 13th
pam turner in a couple of weeks we're
having a march for black women
in baytown texas because if you was
outraged
when you saw the video uh george
slaughter got killed by the police
then you should be equally outraged when
you see the video of how they kill
pam turner an unarmed black woman laying
down on her back
that he shot in the face in the chest
and in the stomach
justice for george floyd means freedom
for us all like for loner says so that's
why we fight for pam turner
uh with that we're going to bring up
people who come from that
harris county uh texas area cousins of
george floyd
charita mcgee and tara brown
well first of all uh let me just say
that
my cousins and who i pretty much covered
everything there's really not a whole
lot left for me to say
i just really want to echo the
sentiments of them
that when we started this journey almost
a year ago
that we were committed to doing a couple
of things one thing is to ensure
that justice was served and that we want
to be here and visible and present and
actively involved
until we saw it through uh we are a
family who's strong in our faith we've
relied on it
in other areas of our life and this time
was no different
and we pray to god and we expected
our prayers to not come back void and he
delivered for us today
so we are eternally grateful for
everyone
from the press to the activists uh
the attorneys the prosecution team
everyone
we have so many people that we want to
thank that i just
really feel like we're probably going to
leave somebody out but i just hope that
you will charge it
to my head and not my heart because we
sincerely appreciate
everything that everybody has done and
we thank you
thank you thank you
wow um i'm really overwhelmed with
emotion
um and i just am grateful
uh for this day it's been a journey for
sure
and this victory for george floyd today
is a victory for many
you know um and when we started this
journey kind of
like my sister said we are committed
to making sure um we know we'll never
get george back
and that's the sad part but we are
fighting and we're going to continue to
fight
because we evolve individually and
together as a family has a conversation
that if we could have been there
with george on that day there probably
would have been more than one day
but we couldn't be there so we can't
bring him back but we can save lives
and we want the actual reform
that's going to not only give us the
change we want
but make sure not another family has to
suffer what we've suffered um
thank you all my sister kind of touched
on everything we have an amazing team
here
who have helped us along this journey we
are so grateful for everyone who has
supported us along the way um
we're forever grateful to you and we
love you all thank you
thank you
so we're gonna hear from two more
uh cousins and then we're going to hear
uh last from the family
roxy and gianna uh
are going to come and then reverend al
may have
reverend jackson and others uh address
you
at this time we're going to have uh
angela and paris
come on cousins of george floyd
hello i'm angela harrelson i'm actually
george with
us and this is the cousin here so anyway
i just want to say that um this has been
a hard role not just
me for the family but for
everybody and i want to especially thank
the minneapolis community for holding it
down
at the george ford square i mean jenelle
austin
you know jeanette rufford maya
washington
these are community leaders that held it
down at that place they kept that place
sacred for everyone to go there to
express their condolences
and so we appreciate that and this
verdict
is a verb that is is well needed
and it's overdue and i want to say to
say to the people around the world that
is listening
it was a darkness on may 25th was a
very very dark day there was a lot of
pain
and it was not a hatred but i want to
say at the same time
that i got a chance to witness something
i got a chance to witness the love
that i saw around the world world that
was forward to the family
i don't know if i would ever see it
again in my lifetime
but i'm glad that i got a chance to see
the love that you have shown
me my family and everyone
because you've touched us and i want to
say thank you
and i'm so glad about this day thank you
i just want to thank everyone again um
all the family up here has basically
said the same thing so
i just want to thank you thank you to
the community
um you all are very special to me
you're just like family yeah and i
appreciate you
at the square um so i'll leave you with
the statement that i always say
um you have to keep walking the walk yes
the journey isn't over so continue to
pray for us
pray for everyone and keep walking the
walk
yes and i want to say one more thing we
must not let his death
be his last word thank you
all right all right and lastly we're
going to have tiffany hall
a system of george moore
i just want to thank everyone for the
support uh we couldn't do this without
you guys
and we appreciate all the time and
energy that you guys have put in
uh to help us get this justice just know
that this is the beginning we still have
a lot of other families we need to fight
for
and we hope and pray that this will
speak volume and we'll have a change
in this world and we won't have to add
any more families
with our families okay so we're really
hoping that this will bring going to
change
thank you guys and thank you tiffany
thank you guys
[Applause]
come back to the podium uh and
acknowledge
some important individuals and then
we're going to take questions
let me say let me say this before we
have
questions i think that it is appropriate
that we respect those that laid the path
for us
and let us always remember those
that cleared the field and made us
possible movements didn't stop with us
we are continuation of movements before
us
and they will be continued until freedom
may we hear from my mentor
the reverend jesse jackson
[Music]
[Music]
bill someone who had
called the police about twenty dollar
bill still operating
social museum and then they're profiting
from people
coming to georgia what the king once
said is
unless we live in our faith prayers live
under the law
jill was killed in 1955 uh
jurors an hour came back by the chuck
dwell
[Music]
cigarette violence
well rarely asked the juror why did you
make each other you know who he was
bragging about he protected his wife
see i could not imagine what in jail for
killing your [ __ ]
that was 55 years 1955 now 231
changes
thank you so much
mr freeman we had the case
he believed it couldn't happen but even
he took the case and had the 12th charge
the first day
he hasn't got the legal team
chester jurors full process led by keith
ellison let's say this is three percent
after america
you
uh minnesota state with great proud
positions brother man
sons of light was destroyed not just by
black and white by roman reigns
there was a massive protest marched by a
white citizen of the state
you stand for justice and jobs this is
the state of human health
who led the struggle for fellow
convention 64.
say the party of the peace
with the state of those who fall down
through the years
when i think about omar being the
congresswoman
simone and um
she's the attorney general's safety was
in black there are the people in this
state
silence alone myself and speak back
fight back
sign up for change i want to express my
thanks all of you coming to me to cover
the story
uh and it's not
people don't a team of uh
chief of black and white and we must
learn
to live together as brothers and not die
apart
live together and not die we live
together
with my thank you to uh mark mariel and
relig
and all those coming up today we're
gonna keep watching
seriously the journal for brother
wright
they list us with the law we're
changing that thank you very much
and lastly before we get to the question
and let me acknowledge again tamika
[Applause]
generations anybody think so get up and
work out with me in the morning
national president of the national urban
league brother mark marielle thank you
very much
first of all i want to be brief but let
me
co-sign amen
and reaffirm all that has been said
today
this conviction rests
on the of a young girl
a young woman who had the audacity
to see an injustice
and to pick up a 21st century device
known as an iphone and to take
that injustice that murder taking place
on the streets of this city
this conviction rests on the
courage of young people
old people black people white people
jews gentiles
protestants catholics muslims hindus
straight
lgbtq of all races creeds and colors
who last summer when they saw the tape
that this young girl made the outrage
went from minneapolis all the way
across this globe and this conviction
rests
on the competence and conviction
of an attorney general named keith
ellison yes sir
you had the wherewithal
to put together a perfect
prosecution and this conviction
rests on the steely determination
and dignity of the floyd family
the floyd family who withering with the
death of their loved ones
stood before cameras testified before
congress
time and time again i'll say this
this fight to pass the george floyd
justice
and policing act has now stepped
to a new level we call on
the united states senate
we call on who the united states senate
to forth with without delay
without filibuster to pass the george
floyd justice and policing act
and not to water it down george floyd
we mourn his loss
may he rest in peace and may he rest in
power
but let us understand that this
is but a moment and this battle this
fight this work for justice
must proceed
as attorney crump comes back for your q
a
let me thank those businessmen that
supported early in this
tyler perry that provided transportation
planes
for the family and all of us robert
smith the millionaire billionaire who
gave private planes for us throughout
the whole thing
uh chuck phillips i want to thank all of
them
and i want to thank rachel nordlinger
for helping
with his communication and the whole
team at national accidentally
they backed me up and make me think good
and the pride i have my baby daughter
ashley
[Applause]
hey you all if you have questions you
can give them to us
uh i understand that president biden
may be waiting to address the nation but
he wanted to give respect to the family
uh i do want to acknowledge the uh
texas coalition of black democrats who
are
helping push the george for a justice
act so at this time
if you have questions you can get with
uh
press president ben crom jennifer
mcguffin
uh reverend we want to be respectful to
the president
good evening first i want to thank the
jury for their service
and i want to thank mr floyd's family
for your steadfast today we feel
a sign of relief still
it cannot take away the pain a measure
of justice
isn't the same as equal justice
this verdict brings us a step closer
and the fact is we still have work to do
we still must reform the system
last summer together with senator cory
booker
and representative karen bass i
introduced the george floyd
justice and policing act this bill
would hold law enforcement accountable
and help
build trust between law enforcement and
our communities this bill is
part of george floyd's legacy
the president and i will continue to
urge the senate
to pass this legislation not as a
panacea
for every problem but as a start
this work is long overdue
america has a long history of systemic
racism
black americans and black men in
particular have been treated
throughout the course of our history as
less than human
black men are fathers and brothers
and sons and uncles
and grandfathers and friends
and neighbors their lives
must be valued in our education system
in our health care system in our housing
system
in our economic system in our criminal
justice system
in our nation full stop
because of smart phones so many
americans have now seen
the racial injustice that black
americans have known for generations
the racial injustice that we have fought
for generations that my parents
protested
in the 1960s that millions of us
americans of every race protested last
summer
here's the truth about racial injustice
it is not just a black america problem
or a people of color problem
it is a problem for every american
it is keeping us from fulfilling the
promise
of liberty and justice for all
and it is holding our nation back from
realizing
our full potential
we are all a part of george
floyd's legacy and our job now
is to honor it and to honor
him thank you and now it is my great
honor
to introduce the president of the united
states
joe biden
today a jury
in minnesota found former minneapolis
police officer
derek chauvin guilty on all counts
in the murder of george floyd's last may
it was a murder in the full light of day
and it ripped the blinders off for the
whole world to see
the systemic racism the vice president
just referred to
there was just immigration as a stain on
our nation's soul
the knee on the neck of justice for
black americans
profound fear and trauma attained the
exhaustion
that black and brown americans
experience every single
day the murder of george floyd
launched a summer protest we hadn't seen
since the civil rights year in the 60s
protests that unified people of every
race and generation
in peace and with purpose to say enough
enough enough of this senseless killings
today today's verdict
is a step forward i just spoke with the
governor of minnesota
who thanked me for the close work with
his team
i also spoke with george floyd's family
again
a remarkable family of extraordinary
courage
nothing can ever bring their brother
their father back
but this can be a giant step forward in
the march
toward justice in america
let's also be clear that such a verdict
is also
much too rare
for so many people seems like it took a
unique and extraordinary convergence of
factors
a brave young woman with a smartphone
camera
a crowd that was traumatized traumatized
witnesses
a murder that lasts almost 10 minutes
in broad daylight for ultimately the
whole world to see
officers standing up and testifying
against a fellow officer
instead of just closing ranks
which should be commended
a jury who heard the evidence carried
out their civic duty
in the midst of an extraordinary moment
under extraordinary pressure
for so many it feels like it took
all of that for the judicial system
to deliver a just just basic
accountability
we saw how traumatic and exhausting just
watching the trial was for so many
people
think about it those are your listening
think about how traumatic it was for you
you weren't there you didn't know any of
the people
but it was difficult especially for the
witnesses
who had to relive that day
it's a trauma on top
of the fear so many people of color live
with every day
when they go to sleep at night and pray
for the safety of themselves and their
loved ones
again as we saw in this trial
from the fellow police officers who
testified
most men and women aware of the badge
serve their communities honorably
but those few who fail to meet that
standard
must be held accountable and they were
today
one was no one should be above the law
and today's verdict sends that message
but it's not
enough we can't stop here
in order to deliver real change and
reform
we can and we must do more to reduce the
likelihood that tragedies like this will
ever happen to occur again
to ensure the black and brown people or
anyone
so they don't fear the interactions with
law enforcement
that they don't have to wake up knowing
that they can lose their very life in
the course of just living their life
they don't have to worry about whether
their sons or daughters
will come home after a grocery store run
or just walking down the street or
driving the car or playing in the park
or just sleeping at home
and this takes acknowledging and
confronting head-on
systemic racism and the racial
disparities that exist in policing
and in our criminal justice system more
broadly
you know state and local government and
law enforcement
needs to step up but so does the federal
government
that's why i've appointed the leadership
of the justice department that i have
that is fully committed to restoring
trust between law enforcement and the
community they are
sworn to serve and protect
i have complete confidence in the
attorney general
general garland's leadership and
commitment i've also nominated
two key justice department nominees
vanita gupta
and kristen clark who are eminently
qualified
highly respected lawyers who have spent
their entire careers
fighting to advance racial equity and
justice
benita and kristin have the experience
and the skill
necessary to advance our
administration's priorities to root out
unconstitutional policing and reform our
criminal justice system
and they deserve to be confirmed
we also need congress to act
george floyd was murdered almost a year
ago
there's meaningful police reform
legislation in his name
you just heard the vice president speak
of it she helped write it
legislation to tackle systemic
misconduct in police departments
to restore trust between law enforcement
and the people they're entrusted to
serve and protect
but it shouldn't take a whole year to
get this done
my conversations with the floyd family i
spoke to them again today
i assure that we're going to continue to
fight for the passage of the georgia
florida justice and policing act
so we can i can sign the law as quickly
as possible
there's more to do finally
it's the work we do every day to change
hearts and minds as well as laws and
policies
that's the work we have to do only then
will full justice and full equality be
delivered to all americans
and that's what i just discussed with
the floyd family
the guilty verdict does not bring back
george
but through the family's pain
they're finding purpose so george
george's legacy will not be just about
his death
but about what we must do in his memory
i also spoke to gianna george george's
young daughter again i met her last year
i've said this before at george's
funeral
i told her how brave i thought she was
and i sort of knelt down and hold her
hand
i said daddy's looking down on you he's
so proud
he said to me then never forget it
daddy changed the world i told her this
afternoon
that he did change the world
let that be his legacy a legacy of peace
not violence of justice peaceful
expression
of that legacy are inevitable and
appropriate
the violent protest is not and there are
those who will seek to exploit the raw
emotions of the moment
agitators and extremists who have no
interest in social justice
who seek to carry out violence destroy
property fan the flames of hate and
division
will do everything in their power to
stop this country's march toward racial
justice
we can't let them succeed this is a time
for this country to come together
to unite as americans there can never be
any safe harbor for hate in america
i've said it many times the battle for
soul of this nation has been
a constant push and pull for more than
240 years
a tug of war between the american ideal
that we're all created equal in the
harsh reality
racism has long torn us apart
at our best the american ideal wins out
so we can't leave this moment or look
away thinking our work is done
we have to look at it we have to we've
looked as as we did
for those nine minutes and 29 seconds
we have to listen i can't breathe
i can't breathe
those are george floyd's last words
we can't let those words die with him
we have to keep hearing those words
we must not turn away we can't turn away
we have a chance to begin to change
trajectory
in this country it's my hope and prayer
that we live up to the legacy
may god bless you may god bless the
george floyd and his family thank you
for taking the time to be here
this can be a moment of significant
change thank you
you